these penguins are having a rest after a
long day looking for food they spend
hours out in the ocean every day hunting
fish to feed themselves and their
children waiting near the shore the
biggest colony of African penguins lives
at the Stony Point Nature Reserve on the
coast south of Cape Town it is home to
about two and a half thousand breeding
pairs Q and McGeorge is a marine ranger
and looks after the colony
he works for Cape Nature the
Conservation Authority for the Western
Cape at this locality without a colony
that's actually growing much the other
of the 27 other colonies penguin
colonies along our southern African
coastline mush them on decline and some
of them are even extinct he counts the
Penguins every week and takes a look at
the chicks and the nests the species is
endangered every penguin counts the
species are struggling the species we
yeah we call it a sentinel specie it's
an indicator species of healthy our
ocean is basically looking at the
biomass if the biomass is poor the
species is is going to struggle
currently we're looking at about 2% 2.5%
of the original stock of African penguin
we down to I think it's about twenty or
thousand pairs breeding pairs
a huge problem for the Penguins is
overfishing they don't find enough to
eat many are killed by ingesting plastic
rubbish or by oil in the water
most colonies are on Islands stony point
is only one of two on the African
mainland and they are both in coastal
towns penguins appear to like Gardens
this one has set up home under a grill
leopards and other predators are
evidently wary about entering developed
areas Maurine biologist dr. Catherine
Lou Denia and her colleague collect data
about the health of the birds if you
tagged the birds to get basically an ID
for each bird to see how long they
survive so we calculate survival of the
species the species is decreasing
dramatically so the numbers are going
down and by seeing how often we see the
birds again through the years we can
calculate what their survival rate is in
what their chances is to survive in the
wild
indirectly tourism helps the Penguins
visitors can take boat rides to Dyer
Island it used to be the biggest
breeding ground for African penguins in
the 1970s there were 25,000 breeding
pairs here but the population has shrunk
dramatically a long-term problem has
been the harvesting of guano the
Penguins used to make burrows in it
income from the boat trips helps fund a
penguin and sea bird sanctuary at Gon's
buy on the mainland with a
rehabilitation centre for the injured
and sick it's got a syllabi twinge and
then now we just clean the wound so he's
not with us for three weeks and we'll
listen as soon as they recover now I'm
about to feed him
when he is fit again he can go back home
penguins play an important role in the
region's ecosystem
other seabirds often settle near their
colonies like these cormorants
seabirds have this interrelationship
interconnectivity we find that the
Penguins you plunge diver who they
co-opted in hunting packs to actually
bring the food to the surface and allow
the other sea birds to feed this
dependence is very important between all
seabirds if you lose the one you lose
the others at stony point the public can
observe penguins up close and learn
about their life and the region's
biodiversity on the boardwalk humans can
observe them without getting in the way
tourism needs to be carefully managed I
think with the correct education and
information given to the to people you
know if ecotourism is balanced properly
then yes it would have a massive impact
but positively but it can also have a
negative impact as well if not
controlled properly
out in the ocean the Penguins are on
their own
and are nearly impossible to protect the
fishing fleets are not concerned about
the Penguins fate if fish stocks
continue to be depleted the Penguins
will face starvation
it's only us as humans that can can
become part of the solution we the
species that can make a choice these
guys don't have a choice you know
big see big swell they must go out and
and go and forage for their daily bread
basically you know regardless of
trawlers plastic debris in the water and
the challenges faced with sharks and
seals these guys are dedicated to
survive so yes there's always hope I
think if we lose hope we lose the
essence of life
you
you